[Music]
the first covet 19 vaccine
one made by pfizer is about to get
authorized by the fda
and the moderna vaccine and others
should soon follow
but those milestones are only small
steps in getting the world back to
normal
the bigger hurdle getting the drugs out
to hospitals across the country
and then into the arms of patients
vaccinating every american will not be
quick or easy
it will require an intricate set of
physical and human logistics
spanning the movement of millions of
vaccine vials on trucks and airplanes
ultracold storage and education
campaigns to help people understand
the risks and benefits so how exactly
will the coven 19 vaccines be rolled out
and when can you expect for a vaccine to
be ready for you
in the u.s the first step in delivering
pfizer's vaccine
will be to move millions of doses from
the drug makers distribution hubs in
michigan and wisconsin
to designated locations throughout the
country one of those places is the
university of cincinnati medical center
in ohio
do you know how many you're getting in
this in this first batch
the way it's being distributed in the
state of ohio is
in lots of 975 doses
the pre-positioning sites will probably
be receiving one package each
initially and then significantly larger
amounts flowing
after that any facility that needs a
smaller amount
than the 975 of the pfizer vaccine
will be receiving it after it is
reprocessed
through the state of ohio into smaller
lots of about 100
doses because of the short supply the
first doses will be reserved for
healthcare workers
the people who work in healthcare are
all essential
so the individuals on that list include
environmental services workers they
include
transporters they include the pharmacist
they include the doctors they include
the nurses
and public safety but this first rollout
will inform how the rest of us get
vaccinated
hospitals like the university of
cincinnati medical center initially
expected to get the vaccine in advance
of the eua
now they're expecting it around december
15th pfizer says it will not distribute
doses before it gets fda authorization
we still don't know exactly when the eua
will be once that's issued
hospitals can start vaccinating their
employees to get doses
each site had to prove that they had the
right kind of equipment to store the
vaccines properly
pfizer's vaccine needs to be transported
in special shipping containers
and stored in freezers that can maintain
ultra cold conditions
not all healthcare facilities have that
kind of storage capacity
modernist vaccine requires less frigid
temperatures
but delivering that one also isn't quite
as simple as distributing flu shots
both the pfizer and moderna vaccines
require two shots
spread over the course of weeks where
are you physically going to be
distributing the vaccine
at the medical center so that's a bit of
a balance too right
we want to be able to have as few sites
as
is functional in order to be able to
maintain quality controls we talked
about the refrigeration issues
so our current plan we have three
facilities that we will be managing
through our initial shipment
is to have one one location at each of
our three facilities
an important goal is to make them
accessible to as many of the first
recipients as possible
that's because another big consideration
is equity and some locations aren't
accessible by public transit
which could limit access figuring out
the human logistics will be just as
important as supply chain in the vaccine
rollout
which is being conducted by the cdc in
three phases
the first is about to start with
priority given to nurses and doctors who
have direct contact with infected
patients or infectious materials
as well as nursing home residents that
amounts to about 24 million people
which exceeds the current number of
available doses
hospitals don't just have to figure out
which employees to prioritize
but also who will be willing to take the
vaccine at least initially
most hospital systems likely won't make
it mandatory everyone has to make their
own decision this is an emergency use
authorization vaccine
that is brand new but we as a society
need as many of the people who are
essential to keeping things functioning
that can take the vaccine to do so the
hospital system sent out a survey to
staff to assess
what proportion would be willing to take
the vaccine now
or ever they fit quite well with the
national averages you're looking at
somewhere between a
50 and 70 and willingness to take the
vaccine
and that's exactly where our employees
sat as well so if you're talking about
from
a herd immunity perspective um numbers
for that
vary quite a bit but most of the time
you hear anywhere from
60 to 75 percent or so of the population
being immune to truly get hurt immunity
herd immunity is
quite a ways down the road probably a
year or more off
administrators are also organizing
education campaigns
to inform staff about the potential side
effects and the vaccine safety
especially given how quickly it was
developed typically it takes an
average of 10 years to develop a vaccine
for covid19 vaccines
development has been measured in months
so it would be very easy
without a really strong understanding of
that process
to assume that the fact that it happened
so quickly when you look back in history
and see how long
other vaccines have taken to produce and
the fact that we have some things that
we can't still produce a vaccine for
to assume that there were corners cut
that we did that
things were done in a sloppy manner or
an unsafe manner to produce a vaccine
and that's just not the case one
organization doing some of that outreach
is the immunization action coalition
where dr lj tan is the chief strategy
officer we need to show
firstly to the providers data as an
evidence so that they feel confident
getting the vaccines themselves and then
we also need to make sure
that they then feel confident giving a
recommendation to their patients because
the number one reason why a patient gets
vaccinated is
is a recommendation from a healthcare
provider
dr tan and others said that the
experience of giving people flu shots
during the pandemic
was what they learned from the first
rollout will help inform covert
vaccinations for the general public
so i think we'll learn a lot about that
um how do you manage to schedule
people um in a way that we don't produce
a social distancing nightmare where
we're trying to give out the vaccine you
know that would be a little bit
counterproductive because
you don't have immunity the second you
get the vaccination we've done
flu campaigns for years but a lot of
times that involves
something that looks a lot like
disneyland where you have these long
lines of people packed
in very closely waiting to their turn
and you just can't do that with this
particular situation because you would
like i said you'd be spreading the virus
within your lines of people getting the
vaccine
[Music]
you